[Music]
if you could would you live on the moon
not as one of the courageous early
settlers but as a citizen of a fully
functioning moon city what would these
cities be built up how different would
your everyday life be and why would
these cities be important this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
built cities on the moon in 2005 a
design called the Shackleton dome caused
a thrill in the aerospace industry this
40 kilometer in diameter and 15 hundred
and 24 meter high glass dome would arch
over the Shackleton crater on the moon
housing the first moon city how viable
was this design domes are the strongest
structural objects and the most
efficient shape to hold air pressure so
building domes to protect people from
the hazards of space is a good idea but
smaller interconnected domes based off
the Shackleton dome would be quicker and
cheaper to build they would be made of
glass and titanium and anchored to
bedrock allowing moon cities to thrive
inside the cities themselves would look
ultra-modern and not because of any
stylistic taste but because aluminum and
Khanh the main components of glass are
the elements found in anorthite a North
Knight is a mineral found on the moon
and would be an important local resource
for construction with so much of it in
the surrounding landscape it would be
foolish not to use it liberally another
popular construction material used in
this futuristic city would be a concrete
like geopolymer created from two
additional readily available materials
moon dirt and your pee yes your Moon
house would be made from urine what
would life be like in these futuristic
cities well you wouldn't experience
normal days and nights anymore one lunar
day is 29 days which means there are two
weeks of darkness and two weeks of light
but because cities would be built around
the moon's poles you would only have to
experience for consecutive Earth days of
darkness at a time your diet would also
change due to the finite resources and
limited space moon cities wouldn't raise
animals for food production so your diet
would be mainly plant-based you might
have the option of eating fish but any
other meat would have to come frozen
from Earth so that wouldn't be very
practical
the moon's major industry would be
mining and exporting helium-3 a
renewable source of energy and other
materials you'd probably have a career
as a scientist engineer or miner as the
Earth continues to use up its precious
resources
the demand for helium-3 would grow
helium-3 is an efficient fuel source in
fusion reactors and sells for roughly
$40,000 US per ounce just 25 tons of it
would power the entire United States for
one year while rare on earth it's found
in abundance on the moon this export
combined with space exploration and moon
tourism would bring a lot of wealth to
moon cities and help repay the expensive
price tag of initial settlement in
construction NASA estimates it would
take 10 billion dollars to build a
settlement on the moon with an extra 2
billion per year in ongoing costs
building cities on the moon would have
to be an international combination of
corporate and government partnerships
currently treaties prevent any one
country from owning the moon if a single
country built a metropolis on the moon
it could be seen as a violation of those
treaties with no single country or
nation the citizens of moon cities would
probably try and form their own
self-governing nation once they became
self-sufficient while domed moon centres
sound like science fiction
they are realistically in our distant
future
settling the moon would open up
opportunities for science engineering
new ways of thinking and further space
exploration it would be a necessity to
create a viable space space to branch
out to other parts of our universe but
before we could construct immense cities
on our moon we would first have to build
initial smaller colonies which involve
their own galactic hurdles but that's a
story for another what if
[Music]
[Applause]